Don King well he's almost as famous as
the boxing matches he promotes recall
the rumble in the jungle and the Thrilla
in Manila with boxing stars such as
Muhammad Ali Joe Frazier George Foreman
and of course Mike Tyson well this
Saturday Don King has a heavyweight bout
scheduled in Las Vegas with Deontay
Wilder going at it with Berman stiverne
Don King joins us now from Las Vegas Don
King great to have you with us explain a
little bit about what's going on this
weekend in Las Vegas and why are you
still doing this well is the return to
glory it is bringing the heavyweight
championship boxing back to the people
and given the people an opportunity to
be the recipient of a glad tiding of an
altercation by the Supreme prowess of
physical attributes and mental acumen
and I think it's going to be a great
great show here at the MGM Grand and it
was the first I open the MGM grand up
with a kirk kerkorian and put the first
boxing match in history here which was
Julio Cesar Chavez and frankly Randall
but I bought Tyson here where I made a
deal with Kurt Weill Tyson was in jail
and and when he came out of jail without
appearing at the MGM Grand and this is
up in a relationship between him and
cliff Pearlman weary established sports
in the area of this great nation of
called Nevada and the city of Las Vegas
so this has a great meaning to all the
people are boxing an introduction to
boxing 40 years ago with Muhammad Ali as
you mentioned was the rumble in the
jungle when he met George Foreman in
Kinshasa Zaire and this was with my boot
haces a sickle and then the ticket from
there to the thriller in Manila with Joe
Frazier and Ali where have met the
protein and Marcos in the milder Marcos
whom I'm still conversing with in the
last 60 days we've been talking hey and
so it's a thing here Don I just want to
get your thoughts though on the current
state of boxing in the United States
you've got these deals with HBO with
Showtime you've got pay-per-view what's
going on with the business of the ring
the business of the ring is what I was
trying to tell you is the history of
they're not fighting of the hair
a championship left in America and it
also left where they have the
heavyweight championship matches because
the criticals would only fight in
Germany they're very nice guy is great
fighters but that only fight in Germany
have pushed upon in fat in Europe but
nowhere in the United States and so we
lost that glamour of the heavyweight
division and now we are reclaiming it as
a return to glory we are reclaiming the
glory of yesteryear of the earliest form
of nuts and the great inimitable Larry
Holmes all of these guys coming back in
the forward them spiritual be here for
everybody to see on Saturday night here
at the MGM Grand gardens and that's when
I especially won't Bloomberg's to be
there because I was there for him when
he was there off when he was starting
out now even up on the Bloomberg TV
Bloomberg Bloomberg hear my cry victory
is what we need in New York you know me
and going on all the way all down the
land right now don't know I want to go
to the greatest fight right here Don I
want to get your thoughts on on Floyd
Mayweather and Manny Picaro Pacquio
Manny Pacquiao yeah ok well let me tell
you what that is this uh the reason that
fat hasn't taken place because there's
been an internal feud with the parties
involved the Hatfields and the McCoys so
to speak and so you have to be able to
resolve that dispute to the agreed that
you could get an agreement this fight
wasn't is luster despite where they will
offer 100 million apiece at one time now
that the fate had lost a little of its
luster because of the two losses of many
Pacquiao but now they're trying to
revitalize it and get it established and
would be what we want it to be a great
fight for the world to see because they
all been clamoring for to see this but
they're going to be clamoring to see
this fight on saturday night p.m. right
here in the MGM Grand Garden when they
see these two heavyweights electrify the
universe when when Deontay Wilder takes
on a perfect record of knockout 30 25 32
knockouts and it takes on Berman who has
22 tracks outs and 26 right that's you
really are good so and as much as the
boxing match